so you know what it's time for
gutfeld industrial hygiene corporation
in conjunction with self-assembling
elves presents
how to be a journalist
with your host brad pitt
[Laughter]
hi i'm your host brad pitt
so let's talk about rolling stone also
known as crap
the once great
now pile of wet garbage published a
story claiming that an oklahoma hospital
was so overwhelmed by patients
overdosing on horse dewormer medications
that actual gunshot victims were stuck
outside in ambulances waiting for beds
meanwhile horses full of worms had to
wait outside because they weren't
wearing masks
now with a story that sounds this on the
nose you'd assume any competent
journalist would reach out to the
hospitals before they write about it
after all these modern facilities have
phones and fax machines and carrier
pigeons and a brand new thing that we
like to call email
having two or more sources verifying
information before you present it his
fact oh but where's the fun in that
but no this is rolling stone
whose readership still hasn't used their
aol free trial cds
it's the weekended bernie's version of
journalism a dead product propped up by
virtue signaling incompetence who
believe instead of think their writing
is so painful they should change their
name to kidney stone
and stephen king has nothing on these
turds when it comes to fiction
especially when they try to own the
rubes the story was originally from
oklahoma's k4 tv quoting some doctor but
then the northeastern hospital system
denied that any patients were treated
for ods and that this doctor actually
hadn't worked at one of the hospitals in
question for months
i haven't seen denial this strong since
the time elton john married a woman
so
there were
absolutely no overdoses related to
ivermectin nor were any patients turned
away due to an overload of such cases
okay but apart from those little details
the story checked out just fine
at first rolling stone kept pushing the
story then it ran an update no
retraction and then when it just got too
big to bury they ran a humiliating
correction but not before a pile of
liberal mainstream media figures
embraced their crap spreading it all
over the web rachel rachel maddow
tweeted about it joy reid who apparently
still has a job promoted the story on
her show
the emergency room in one rural oklahoma
town is being overwhelmed by people
overdosing on ivermectin the horse
deworming medication it's gotten so bad
that gunshot victims gunshot victims are
having to wait to be treated
great job there joy but maybe it's time
msnbc got treated for worms
after all how many times have their
hosts look like a horse's ass
drew holden compiled a list of suckers
who bought this story from business
insider to the guardian mindless dupes
like justin baragona of the daily beast
and roland martin who doesn't know his
elbow from his ascot there was an msnbc
producer and so on these idiots are
wrong more often than biden trying to
button up his shirt
so what's the lesson here
well the fake story took off without
anyone within that media bubble applying
the brakes instead they placed both
their feet on the gas pedal why is that
well first of all the media is not our
best and brightest people present
company excluded of course
hell you find better and smarter folks
in the front row of a midnight cockfight
in guam
especially those whose only content is
clickbait designed to make their leftist
consumers feel superior and that's what
the story did it gave their patients a
dose of dumb redneck therapy
something to chat about while sunshine
the barista screws up your latte and
this ain't the first for rolling stone
they were responsible for one of the
most damaging hoaxes ever a piece called
a rape on campus which described a gang
rape at the university of va a crime
that never happened they gleefully ran
with it even though the reporting had
bigger holes in it than hunter biden set
them
they later retracted the story you know
after the lives of the accused were
ruined forever uva's reputation was
severely tarnished and american colleges
went into a full-blown panic due to a
make-believe campus rape epidemic
you'd think they'd learn but to learn
you have to suffer unpleasant
consequences meanwhile rolling stone
just got a new editor in chief from of
all places the daily beast that's like
hiring your babysitter from death row
it's a bummer i grew up idolizing
rolling stone when the clash or cheap
trick made the cover it validated my
life because those were my bands so i
tolerated their editors commie leftism
because i loved the music now it's a
mess
rolling stone is to journalism as
barfing into an air conditioner is to
air conditioner repair
but maybe they always sucked and i
didn't know it after all rolling stone
panned led zeppelin's first two albums
jimi hendrix first album they panned
black sabbath's first album nirvana's
never mind neil young's harvest the
rolling stones exile on main street
need i go on
why isn't this magazine locked up in
gitmo where it belongs
but perhaps they should stop doing music
altogether and stick to
politically owning the rubes here's some
cover ideas
transgender raccoon families
babies or rabies
why you should never trust white people
except for us because we liked tracy
chapman
800 pound man dies at hot dog eating
contest
covid
suspected top 500 songs of all time
number one my humps by black eyed peas
actor tom hanks has temporarily passed
away
why aren't they called african-american
sabbath
finally
dewey defeats truman
still magic so just embrace it rolling
stone because your past role as a
respected music magazine is over you may
be a rolling stone but your grave has
been gathering moss for years hey sean
hannity here hey click here to subscribe
to fox news youtube page and catch our
hottest interviews and most compelling
analysis you will not get it anywhere
else